welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens and this is the sneak
peek where we take the temperature of
the future of nerdom and joining me
today is my best friend in the entire
universe Brandon Barry oh my goodness
what a title to give me Jessica thank
you so much I'm so happy to be here with
you today yeah I know it's a very rare
title only like 20 people have it oh
only 20 people oh I that's still 20 out
of uh 7 billion that's pretty good
that's pretty good I'll take it what
should we talk about on sneak peak today
Jessica what we're going to talk about
today is
that's right that's right Ekko is going
to be Marvel's first Spotlight series
they're dropping all five episodes on
Disney plus uh next year which is not
far away don't you love to say that see
you next year what's the date again
exactly January 10th 2024 why is that so
important other than echo's coming out
it's someone's birthday and I can't
remember whose oh well maybe it'll come
to me oh uh even though this release
date for Echo is over a month away uh
Marvel has sent out a few screeners
recently to the Press we're starting to
get a taste of some of the initial
reactions to this series right so what I
thought we could do today here on sneak
peek is go through some of these
reactions and see if we can get a sense
of what the series will be like and
whether or not Marvel might have a
little hit on its hands a cute little
hit to start off 2024 beautiful I'm
ready for it I'm ready for it too I'm
really excited about this show now I was
excited when they announced the show I
loved the character of Ekko when they
appeared on Hawkeye last holiday season
holidays 2022 we had that Hawkeye series
but then like kind of the news came out
last year that the series was moving
release dates this show was supposed to
come out last spring and then it got
moved to like November and then they
were like oh just kidding we're putting
it out in January and we're going to
drop all the episodes at once something
Marvel has not done with any past series
before so I got a little worried right I
was a little like uh maybe they don't
like this show well to be fair I guess
it happened to every show cuz they just
like Iron Heart uh blade has no date uh
here's all the other shows that are and
it's not only Marvel it's a lot of sure
a lot of things and like when they moved
it from last spring to November part of
that and then in November they're like
oh we're moving it again part of that
was the strikes right the writer strike
the actor strike you know they needed to
fix things they needed to finish stuff
they want to have people promoting the
show it wasn't it originally like right
after Loki yeah well yes it was going to
be right after Loki but like originally
originally it was like the spring of
2023 they always say one date the first
and I know that first date is going to
always change that second date I was so
nervous about I was like that doesn't
seem I really hate that they're doing
this and they're dropping it all at once
you're like uh I was nervous and then
they said January 10th and I said I'm
not nervous
anymore best best gift in the world well
and you know to be fair a lot of Marvel
series have been criticized in the past
for kind of either being slow or like
the Standalone episodes maybe aren't
great episodes of Television right so
sometimes like some of those series I
think benefit from a binge watch where
you can just kind of like move right
through it cuz they kind of feel like a
movie that's been cut into six parts
right rather than like like oh this is a
series where each episode has its own
little mini Arc and they all build up to
the greater bigger Arc of the series so
that could be exciting for the show
right maybe it works better as something
you digest over one sitting or one or
two days how many episodes is it five
five episodes okay are you really even
binging at that point cuz I'm like five
is pretty good unless they're hourlong
episodes that we don't know yet right we
don't know the length we don't know the
length of the episode yet I mean the
longest Marvel uh Disney Plus shows and
I'm just going off the Dome here don't
have a number in front of me I think the
longest ones like with credits get to
like 56 58 minutes none of them
content-wise have been over an hour
right they're they're all kind of tight
like that uh I personally I don't love
binging shows I I I used to like it but
like I I love it when you can like watch
an episode of television and take some
time to think about it process it yes I
want to know what the story is I want to
keep going but sometimes I think when we
binge television shows we're focusing on
like the a plot of the series right we
want to know that overarching story we
miss out on the B or C plots sometimes
yeah that's a good thing about you and
you're a great person for that I'm I
don't think it makes me a good person no
I wish I was like uh I need to take a
break away from it I'm like no let me
ingest it all right or digest it all
right now uh it it could be the
millennial pause as they say uh it's
called the millennial pause I pause and
I watch the entire thing in one evening
my Roman Empire is binging everything so
before anyone else you you will stay up
I remember when the uh the most recent
season of I forget the show not one
piece I did with one piece no what's the
other hero Show on Netflix the comic
book show Umbrella Academy when that
last season dropped you start you
watched it from like midnight till 4: or
5 in the morning and I was like Jessica
what are you doing I do a stranger
things too it's it it it's two things
it's out of fear of someone spoiling it
immediately if I give it too long of a
time and then also just being the king
of the castle you want to know I need to
know secret so I'm going to binge this
regard yeah it'll be hard not to we're
still on the on the new rockstars
Channel we're going to break down
Episode by episode uh that's still going
to happen we're not going to Bunch it
all into one breakdown I believe that's
the plan if we change that plan please
go back and edit this out uh but yeah
we'll still we'll still take it episode
by episode but yeah it's going to be
hard not to watch this thing all in one
city and hopefully it's great and and
then we live through it right because
all my trepidation about this series
from the moving round of dates that all
changed when that trailer dropped that a
good trailer right freaking trailer I
was surprised by that trailer that
trailer was giving I I remember as soon
as I watched it I was like damn what I
was I was like snatch I was like this a
snatch this is like every gun Thug movie
I've ever seen in my entire life and I
was like this is different yeah
especially after um Hawkeye right when
people criticize Hawkeye for being a
little silly a little campy at times
especially with the violence you know
you had like the larpers even Kingpin
seemed a little Jolly not as menacing
right he was wearing a shirt yeah was a
Christmas Fe of the show now granted
that show has some of the most violent
conceptual things the the three
tracksuit Mafia dudes who Get shrunk
down in their truck Obsessed the owl Tak
them on away you know what an owl does
to its prey it holds it down with his
talent and it picks it up high with his
beig but it poops them all out in once
because they don't have the No No ows
cannot poop out the hair and the bones
and stuff they poop out the me out the
meat and then they barf out the pellets
in fifth grade we would dis here has
dissected an out I don't know that I
thought that was a weird southern thing
I'm glad to hear that existed it was
always yeah cuz it was also like you put
together the bones of a rat or something
yeah it was the most Humane thing that
ick other than a plant we did plant
plants have feelings plants are alive
okay continue my plant Brethren rise
up I saw the happening I you think this
is The Happening um so yeah that trailer
drops now I'm like very pumped for this
show I can't wait I hope it's good uh so
what what I thought would be fun to do
on sneak peek today Jessica if you'll
allow me if you'll give me the
permission sh okay thank you uh let's go
through some of these early kind of
reviews these musings that have dropped
on on Twitter uh and we'll see if we can
make sense of them and just a reminder
like Jessica and I we have not seen any
of these screeners uh we're gonna We're
not gonna be in seen all she's lying
she's lying look at
her she's lying uh we have not going to
be intentionally spoiling anything about
this show but I don't know if you find
these kind of early reviews spoilery I
don't know these are very quick hits
that we're on Twitter uh that we kind of
rounded up here okay so first up let's
look at a tweet from Disney plus news
they said I've got to see the first
three episodes they saw three uh three
out of five more mature than other
Disney plus Marvel shows huh great fight
scene with Daredevil okay I don't know
if that's a spoiler we assume Daredevil
would be on the show I think it was
announced Daredevil would be on the show
loved Kingpin he's not a great guy to
love I don't think he'll love a Kingpin
uh feels more like TV they have in
parenthesis there lower Stakes perfect
for the new Spotlight brand can't wait
to see other episodes on January 10 what
do you think of that is that a good sign
for you does that sound good that once
you said feels like TV I was like then
they got vague I think a lot of the
criticism around some Marvel Disney Plus
shows is that they were like trying to
be movies right it's like the world's at
Peril right most recently division was
literally TV shows W division was great
I I I think I think in this conversation
W Division and Loki they're fine right
they they exist we all love them no
notes some notes uh but things like the
most recent secret Invasion for example
the trying to tell this like story about
the world even though you we only meet a
few characters and we only go to a few
places like there was probably a smaller
story they could tell there that would
be more effective
right I guess or like uh moonight right
they it ends with this big battle at the
pyramids and the world's at stake and
there's lasers going or there's a light
going into the sky right that kind of
stuff that's a little big I think that's
what they yeah but it's also I I guess
it's just me it's just I'm like yeah
it's also a Marvel mov that's like
that's not a Marvel movie Marvel it's a
Marvel property that's like saying hey
uh Transformers I want you to make a
series and expecting it not to be huge
Out of Space Battles but what if it's
just a series about the Transformers
dealing with a problem in their Hometown
then go make a grounded show for AMC
trying to do they're trying to do that I
want you to keep making my Fast and
Furious well and people love those like
Netflix uh Marvel shows right much
beloved they felt a little more like on
the ground street level heroes doing
street level things that's not a I don't
think that's an on the ground type show
it felt more on the ground than what
we've been getting everything else is I
mean it this is space people on Earth
but he even says like no this is my
battle on Earth he doesn't really go to
space in secret Invasion until the very
beginning and the very end yeah we don't
see him in yeah we never do so that's
why I'm like yeah I don't yeah but it's
dealing with the president of the United
States uh the prime minister of the UK
uh some dude from the UN that's grounded
for us that's not grounded that's
grounded for us in the MCU are you out
of your mind you're out of your mind
you're out of your mind you're out of
your
mind then all the special effects right
like they're not quite finished yet
they're a little sloppy like they if if
it had been a movie it might have been a
little more cleaned up okay here's the
next review we're going to look at is
from Tom peral of the digital fix they
said saw the first two episodes of echo
tonight they didn't get that third one
uh and I have a lot of thoughts I think
fans of Netflix as Daredevil are going
to love it it's like Marvel remembered
it can be violent and dark ooh uh alaka
Cox is amazing great to hear although I
don't love all the creative decisions
though understandable I like that one I
can see that one little honesty there at
the end I also love that they especially
with Eko they were like we can't lineen
up on the darkness of like I like that
they were trying to stay gritty into
that cuz it is like this is Kingpin this
is a man that kills with his fist like a
man that literally uses his ants he
doesn't use weapons and I'm like and
then we have uh Ekko who also is doing
the same thing these people don't really
have superpowers they just very strong
yeah no lasers no magic and their stuff
is their money making is literally in
Thug activity so I'm genuinely gangster
activity so I'm literally like yeah make
this as greedy as you can I just don't
want to see another I'm trying to
imagine like a gangster film or
something that's just like kind of bland
I American Gangster staring out all they
shot at my wife it's not Bland at all uh
but I I want it I like the take that
they're taking from what I see in the
trailer it's like that gray black not
black and white gray and black of like
I'm still figuring myself out but I'm
also killing a lot of people right right
right the flashback we got of her story
in Hawkeye like the death of her father
was very violent and tragic and
traumatic for it I I hope they do not
stay completely to the comics for eeko
but it's like the eeko comics are so
beautiful but they're so gritty it's
this girl that's literally like dealing
with everything her dad died when she
was young her entire life has been like
hey I'm going to avenge my father just
figure out the man that has pretended to
be her new father is the one that did it
so she's just like I'm falling I don't
know what I'm doing I believe this man I
trusted this man and everyone around me
I can't trust anymore what am I going to
do and I want that to come through in
this show and I want to focus on that a
lot and I wanted to be just as like nice
as the comics did it as crisp as
beautiful there were blades in the
issues they're like blades yeah like
like cutting blades like razor blades
the way they did the art for like uh
it's Daredevil's Man Without Fear run
that's about Echo the art is so
beautiful but they're also like sad and
gritty and dark and like there's razor
blades along the edges and it's like
yeah this is a girl that like had to
fight for her entire life so I want it
yeah what you kind of hinted to there
Jessica like the journey back to Kingpin
in a way of like you know that's her
only family left in a way I mean we
might learn more about her roots in this
show but like she's raised by her father
like in New York you know she's already
feels kind of outed from society from
being deaf she's an amputee like she she
must feel like an outsider in this world
she loses her father she finds out it
was Kingpin that ordered that that's
what was discovered on the Hawkeye
series and she shoots him in the
face as you do and now he's like he's
not he's not gone so she's going to have
to deal with that right and it's like do
you accept that do you go back to that
or do you try and like form your your
new path and those are the parts in the
comic books that they get into of like
every step of the way after that
shooting what did she do and it's like
going back is she more in the comic
books is she more of a hero more of like
a villain did she kind of stay in the
criminal she she started like a a hero
she never was kind of a hero because she
was lied to her entire life so she the
kingpin's like hey this guy killed your
dad Daredevil and she's like oh well I
got to go kill him and then she's also
simultaneously in love with him and
doesn't know that it's Matt Murdoch yet
so it's like she is not it feels bad to
say she's a villain or a hero because
she doesn't know yet what she is and in
the comic she figures that out and she's
like oh I'm just me um and I need to do
my own thing beauti so it's really good
read the men without fear issues with
Ekko they're very beautiful and the
story is really great and it gets into
her tribe and it talks about like she
goes into the mountains to like go find
herself she runs into Wolverine as you
if you go to the mountain you're going
to run into Wolverine and it was funny
because she was like is this a giant
beast and it was just Wolverine
wandering the forest stinky ass
Wolverine and it was like raining she
couldn't see she's like is this a wolf
and it was just like Wolverine like hey
I want to the forest Ser now I haven't
had a chiz shave on time voice I I think
they'll pull it through in the comics
it's very important okay okay here's
another review we got uh Emily Murray
from Total film saying enjoyed the first
two episodes of eeko which had an
incredible and violent fight scene I
want to watch again and again the sound
design is fire shout out to the sound
design on this show the brilliant Alaqua
Cox continually draws me in but I found
the storytelling and pacing shaky
excited to see the rest shaky is a good
way I would describe storytelling and
pacing on these Marvel shows sometimes
if you get five episodes in 30 minutes a
piece there's only so much you can
really well that's like a a heavy movie
right that's like a a heavy movie that's
two and half hours it's a series where
you're like you get to explore more and
then I get the thing about um Marvel
also is like sometimes you put too many
hands in the pot and that's my that's
always my fear because this is like a
show that is also trying to give Ekko
her own platform to actually breathe
because we only got to see her in
Hawkeye which is not enough to see her
and then we're also introducing like oh
yeah here's King Pin again and here's
Daredevil again and here's all these
other people and I'm like do we have
enough time in five episodes to explore
who Ekko is what she's doing but also
incorporate Kingpin and Daredevil into
it five episodes I don't know that's
yeah because they want to tie in you
know this show and there's another
villain there's a third right this show
is establishing different from the
comics that like Eko is from the Chaka
tribe in Oklahoma and like they want to
approach that side of the story a little
bit from the trailer it looked like
we're going to see the past potentially
right V either Visions or an actual
moment from the past uh we'll see how
that all plays into the show but yeah
it's a lot to kind of pckage to one
little Marvel crime show and we're I
know we're going to get flashbacks with
her father Hawkeye wasn't about eeko
Hawkeye is about K Bishop hawkey like
and then the third person would be Elena
Bova um and then Ekko and Kingpin but or
Ekko and so I'm like we only got that
glimpse of Ekko and her father from
Hawkeye so we're going to get those
flashbacks a lot in this year especially
if she's going back to like talk to
anyone in her tribe it's probably like
oh what was my dad's part in this tribe
as well there's a shot in the trailer
where she's like standing at his grave
yeah we assume it's his grap it's
probably his grave one shot energy I
I'll try one I'll try one and if it
doesn't wake me up I'm going to be
pissed oh
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah I know K
[Music]
Fu okay I want to try the focus ones now
eternity okay one shot is really all I
need I think they both clashed in me and
now I don't know where I'm at begin your
transformation with one shot energy
today by going to oneshot energy.com
neww Rockstar for 10% off your order I
am going crazy I am an insane person I
have to go see a musical I have to go
sit in a theater oh my God here's
another review for you Tyrell Charles
saying uh I've seen three episodes of
eeko a grounded character-driven story
with hints of bigger things to come the
strong focus on Maya's indigenous
Heritage and personal history intrigues
me and while some Quiet Moments slow the
pacing when the action scenes come they
are indeed brutal oh yeah she's this is
I'm not finished yet Jessica how dare
you interrupt me and and Tyro Charles
this is uh Maya Lopez origin story
through and through honestly after all
the huge confusing CGI Multiverse stuff
lately a more gritty street level story
is quite refreshing to me and I'm sure I
won't be alone in that thought are you
done I'm done I'm I'm completed okay
thank you I am completed I am completed
review complete that's a good one I like
that one yeah I think again I appreciate
that like people recognizing like hey
maybe this pacing is a little slow maybe
that but uh it seems like these first
couple of reviews they recommend the
action they like the action I'm seeing
the word gritty used a lot grounded I
think these are things we want to see in
a show uh kind of take us back to Our
Roots a little bit take us back to Our
Roots maybe dip our toes in the Netflix
water and see what we like what I like
about it a lot is that which I don't
think we're really going for in Ekko or
with Ekko but she's basically Bullseye
and she can mimic immediately but she's
much cooler than Bullseye because
Bullseye sucks but not uh he's he's a go
back and watch Dil are we going off on
Bullseye now go back and watch Daredevil
he takes FAL the dead girl that he
stalks and drives through a building
with Earth corpse it's crazy I like
Callin pharoh Bullseye with the with the
marks in his head the marks in his head
no this so Eko a much cooler version can
mimic everything and I like that in that
violent grittiness maybe it's like also
mimicking Netflix's Daredevil where it's
like yeah just like the first episode of
Daredevil is like this is going to be
sad and hor horrible well and it it
sounds like maybe she's fighting
Daredevil a little bit are they going to
be at odds is she going to be protecting
Kingpin from Daredevil I want to really
know how a daredevil is going to be
incorporated in this he's not just going
to show up out of nowhere when we last
saw him in La so he going to be getting
off the plane uh from LA and he's going
to be like God damn my hips are killing
me oh Jesus she really beat me up and
ekko's going to be like hey I'm on to
you she's like I'm on to you I'm I'm
excited to see that connection but I
like the idea of I I'm obsessed with
everyone saying this is violent and just
gory I mean that trailer was violent
I beating that ice cream salesman I dare
you I dare you you s the ice cream I
love her it's also it's that part I
can't wait for that to come through that
like other than Vanessa this is probably
the only other person that he cares
about cares about you think we'll see
Vanessa on the show I hope not uh not an
echo not an echo uh because I can't wait
to see that episode of him be like which
he did in the comics he's like I still
love you you I love you you're my
daughter you shot me in the face he's
like I care about you and I'm like ew
this is horrible you killed my father
and then like he he ordered the killing
he ordered the killing yes I keep going
back to the comic where he literally did
and then he didn't even really want her
to begin with he was just like okay I
guess I'll take her and then he found
out she's a prodigy and was like
beautiful in music and you know how he
is with the Arts uh and so this I'm like
it's it's
so Messier I like it though the idea
that like he loves this child it's the
same still did that to her tried to hide
it from her she finds out shs him in the
face and kingpen a guy who holds his
grudges yeah is willing to be like you
know what this is on me I should make
nice this is what God this is and not
the same at all anal not a good analogy
what I love about Tangled where I'm like
oh yeah let's let's talk about Tangled
she's keeping her from the outside world
are you about to forgive Mother Gothel
for what she did never that's why I'm
saying those are like the weird lore
that we get into with Disney is just
like how bad it is when we we don't how
messed up it is we don't really think
about it and it's like she was
manipulating this girl in a tower
forever saying like if you go out there
you're going to get attacked by men
you're fat like was saying all these
weird things Cinderella's dad was around
not doing anything doing anything while
they're making Cinderella do all this
[Music]
[__] and it's the same like weird
manipulated behavior that Kingpin is
doing of like I still love you I know
that I and I wasn't honest with you but
I want you to know that going forward
maybe I will be also I got a great I got
a great opportunity for you to make a
million dollar you got to kill this man
at a red suit I want you to kill this
man at a red suit I don't like it now
this suit's gold and red I hate it even
more mustard and catch a
God give me Spiderman when's kingping
gonna fight Spider-Man when is he gonna
fight Jo J I hope they established are
the same person they are and they're
best [__] friends dude oh you know
they're friends they're all my you know
they meet up at he pays that new site
they meet up at the RNC they're really
good friends they go back to the hotel
room they been mow a couple of ladies to
come
over your name's Vanessa tonight
Vanessa go to the next go to the next
okay well before we continue on with our
our great show that's going super well
getting lots of Thumbs Up from dashel uh
be sure to check out nerd rot. shop
where you can always grab the latest and
greatest in new rockstars gear uh we
just put up some great new holiday
designs including a play on Christmas
stories iconic frile lamp this bad boy
here with Iron Man's leg oh booah happy
holidays huh huh frile we also got this
cute little Deadpool and Groot naughty
or nice I don't know which one's which
you tell me we also got this awesome
shirt that I came today that I'm wearing
this is kind of like in the vein of that
what if episode where they're all going
to be racing around on a car but like
it's all these characters old school
kind of comics look at that Thor I can't
do backwards order your stuff now and
you get it in time for Christmas I
believe the last day to do that is like
December 11th so if you're watching this
get on it uh go to nerd rot. shop is a
great way to support the channel check
out all of our awesome merch options
over there get something from earlier in
the year that you miss that you were
waiting around for uh that is nerd riot.
shop check it out okay you can stop
holding the are you keep holding them
the whole show I don't know cute do you
like this no do you like these do you
like me now Mommy now that I have these
t-shirts now that I have these t-shirts
Mommy and hey while we have your
attention don't forget to subscribe to
all three channels of the new Rockstar
Network new rock stars the Deep dive and
the
breakroom let's take on some more
reviews are you ready I'll read this I
can read Kenny G i Kenny G say it's I
Kenny J I can't why did I say G I don't
know because Kenny G is we all know
Kenny G you know I'm think I'm thinking
of Cass G you were thinking of Kenny G
the infamous Kenny G from Mean Girls
what did you say no Kenny G who plays
the the tener
Sachs has one of the most famous
Christmas ALB all timeing girl is like
the boy that raps he his name might be
Kenny G also but Kenny G has the curly
hair is that a normal person he plays a
tener Sachs we will edit this out but I
is that a normal person well do people
know him for that I was born in 2002
okay and I know who Kenny G is but he
goes Kenny G when he sings he might in
his rap he might the most obscure suck
MC nothing on me for the bra can't touch
keny I'm a mathlete
word I kennyj said saw the first three
episodes of Marvel Studios # Echo you
don't have to say hash but it's okay my
got to okay personally I didn't enjoy
all parts show is definitely brutal dark
has calm moments with a strong focus on
Maya also Daredevil fans will no doubt
like what they did in the show that's
good doing Daredevil right I think it's
still T speaking to the vibe Vibe of the
show reminding us of Daredevil's Netflix
I also love that a few of these reviews
have pointed out like strong focus on
the character of Maya it's like the show
is called echo which maybe that's a
indictment of previous MCU title where
they're all over the place in the most
uh not to play Devil's Advocate when you
hear about the cast that's showing up
you're like yeah I know it's Echo but
you're also putting five other people
yeah there's Kingpin there's Jed you're
like so you're like who show is this who
show is that's how I feel about uh
Captain America I'm like there was like
eight other people in there oh Civil War
yeah barely a Captain America I Hear You
Slanders Civil War again I'm not
slandering I'm just saying it's it's
barely a Captain America movie oh my it
is it feels like an Avengers movie it is
an Avengers movie they they'll change
the title in like 20 years Paul kleene
or Paul clean I think I like Klein Klein
makes more sense yeah uh film hounds
magazine if the world ending Stakes of
the MCU have you longing for something
more grounded # Echo is the gritty tonic
two episode scene and it's how do people
choose what how many episodes they get I
think some some got two based on like
photos people had posted with their
tweets uh which you probably at home you
might be seeing these I link them in the
descript if the post team didn't put
them in I'll be
[Music]
angry some of the pictures that look
like some people went to a screening and
I I assume some people were maybe sent
screeners okay so some people probably
went to a screening at a theater where
they only showed two okay we'll continue
two episode scene and it's a
hard-hitting action thriller with a oo
Thriller with a great sense of Native
American culture can't wait to see the
final three when they drop in January
one that has actually talked about the
cultural Native American references that
are going to be made in the show well
and I'm wondering if there is like an
episode where there more in the past or
something that's four or five right like
they haven't really got I bet episode
four will be her act that's usually like
around you know that kind of like
penultimate episode they throw in a yeah
and then by the bottom the end of that
episode she looks in the camera and
goes and then they go to fight and
they're ready to fight ready fight the
music swells and then credits oh thank
God they dropped all episodes I can
watch right now I have to wait perfect
now I don't have to wait um again
reiterating they keep saying brutal and
Thriller every single one of these
reviews are like brutal gritty dark I'm
also like what do you watch normally
Bluey cuz I I watch dark movies so I'm
like I want to see a fist go through
someone's mouth man I back the bluey you
know what I'm talking about I love me
some Bluey all dogs are good yeah not
all dogs go to heaven not this dog over
here let me tell you let me tell you
right now not this dog Cobra Kai Nation
said so I've watched three episodes of
Eko and I really enjoyed it alaka
performance as Maya's natural and superb
the series dark and gritty style
storytelling is exactly what the MCU
needs there's some moments in that had
me EST static energetic and excited #
Echo fun yeah that was a good yeah so
what do we think what do we want to see
more of in the series uh that we didn't
get another MCU Series yeah I mean I'm
loving that it seems to really be
focused in on this character give us
like what I would love to see is like a
good kind of kind of like backstory to
really show us this character's
motivations understand what their
motivations are uh and know their place
in the world I also want at one point in
the show for her to turn to the uh some
character to turn to the camera and
explain exactly what's going on with ti
in the ocean I don't think this and they
will also tell us what happened to
xandar if xandar is still around or not
I don't think will be like you know you
know my xandar was completely destroyed
by Thanos you know you know also there's
a giant there's a giant Celestial made
up marble
and I'm going to build an apartment
complex there with vaness I was about to
say you know damn well kingpin's trying
to find a way to send some goons out
there a little chunk we got get some
goons out there we got to run that
Island I'm I got a piece of that
mountain man Mighty right right here do
you think this series will kind of
establish is this the same Kingpin from
Netflix is this the same no he's not
because he showed up in a Hawaiian
t-shirt in Hawkeye the man could have
worn one in the netlix
do it though that's not how it works we
didn't see him in his private moment
even if they address it and say like we
don't have any confirmation about
Daredevil right yeah they they've been
very Cy about like if they're the same
ones if they're different ones my my
feeling is that like the Netflix
timeline is in the 616 but it's a
separate Branch timeline I think that's
what they're going to do with all of
those things I guess what do you think
would be so different from that Kingpin
to this other than the Fedora and the
and
the why I mean if this Kingpin is really
like rebuilding an Empire is like has
lost a lot since the Netflix days maybe
during the blip like lost a lot or
something like but he still have that
same drive and ambition ambition like
good person he still have that drive and
that anger still I don't think it's
going to be like too off I think it was
really the direction in the shooting
that Daredevil Netflix had for Kingpin
that would change for what it is in the
MCU but I still think it's still the
same kind of story like my dad I hate
him him I killed him my
cuffs still ripping people apart yeah I
think that part's still going to stay
which is fine right yeah I just want to
just tell this story and kind of focus
on that and not worry too much about the
other stuff I don't need to know what
you know the Avengers are up to or all
that stuff what do you think in this
series that the writers and maybe the
directors like took from the other MCU
series and maybe movies that they're
like oh we should either not do that or
we should try to focus more on this do
you think there's going to be like a
huge difference well it sounds like you
know uh She-Hulk and this is not the
responsibility of the creators of that
show this was the marketing right they
they showed us Daredevil was going to be
on that show and then he didn't show up
till like episode six or something like
way way way way later it sounds like
Daredevil's in at least the first three
episodes at some point like they get
that out of the way right it's
interesting because the stuff that I've
seen we're not really talking about
Daredevil we're talking about Kingpin
and Echo every time I see something it's
just Kingpin Echo he's being mentioned
here it sounds like there's a fight
sequence it would make sense that
Daredevil and Eko would square off for
some reason if ekko's sneaking around
somewhere and Daredevil's like hey I
don't I don't like this what if it is
Bullseye oh man what if it's bionic
Bullseye from Netflix from Netflix it
could be like it's a red souit guy
that's my favorite part is we always
call bullseyes the red suit guy like he
copied the suit and was like I am a
daredevil and what if he does that
again get on to the railroad tracks um
let me tie you down um but no I would
love even that to happen because that
fight between XO and Bullseye would be
just as good is there something in you
haven't seen yet in a Marvel series that
you would love to see in this show the
thing is the parts that I love about the
Marvel series I don't think they've made
especially Bob Iger has made very much a
note that we don't we shouldn't do it
what's that I I'm a brown woman and I'm
like yeah I love these stories when
you're diving my favorite part about
Miss Marvel was when she went back in
time and I got to see that and
experience that culture I was like this
is stuff that I didn't really actually
get to learn a lot of and I know it's
like no one's job to teach I should be
learning that stuff but I'm like it's
opening my eyes and it's opening a lot
of children's eyes to these situations
and so with Ekko that's what I'm hoping
to get I'm like I want to dive into this
character I want to explore her and if
her culture being like Native American
is a big part of her I want to explore
it yeah and it sounds like they've taken
a lot of care with that like the writer
room was very diverse some you know
diversity and like the creators of the
show production staff that worked on
like reservation dogs like worked on
show so it's like they want to tell that
story they want to be honest and
truthful with it which I appreciate cuz
yeah I mean a lot of characters from
Marvel have backgrounds that were not
treated properly you know and I think
this kind of these last couple phases of
Marvel they've tried to address that and
like fix these things up a little bit
and make them uh a little better a
little more powerful yeah it's it's so
unfortunate with how a lot of fandoms
fans will act about it but I'm like yeah
I love these things and I want them to
cherish Eko Eko didn't get my biggest
thing about Ekko is like as soon as they
announced her series I was like I'm
gonna watch the hell out of the series
but we did not give her room to breathe
in hot gu and so no one knew what Echo
the series was going to originally be
about and I'm so glad this trailer
kicked ass cuz now people are like oh
[__] I want to see this she fights like
oh my God like she's fight from she's
from the streets born raised from the
streets and I'm like yeah she's a badass
read her comics it's amazing like she's
a beautiful amazing person uh and I just
want all of that to be shown and put
through and I want people to be as
excited as I am heck yeah uh all I want
out of this show is Jubilee
okay cut cut to my camera cut to my
camera dead also no actually cut the
camera's dead ass shut this man up once
and for all I'm not having this dog in
my studio I think this is how we get
Jubilee in the MCU we bring her in
through Echo we bring her in through e
right when we said that there's a lot of
people the post credit scene will be
eeko going to an arcade a young woman is
trying to play a game and it Sparks do
you think we're going to get a post
craing it's the black kid from hero I
think I think they'll have to do I mean
there will be a post-credit scene they
do that it happens yeah do we well miss
Marvel's was just that she's a mutant
yes and then She-Hulk was the reveal
that Hulk had a son yeah so it won't be
like post crb but you think the very
last episode I think the very I I don't
think every it'll be the very last
episode we have like something at the
post that's the episode where Daredevil
shows up the f is the post credit SC is
a 20 minute post maybe like you know I
don't know if this would be the actual
thing but what I would like what I would
like I think would be fun and wouldn't
be too much of a high stakes thing to
gamble with is uh all this [__] goes
down every piece of it every little
piece of it they somehow get kingfin in
prison and his lawyer is Jennifer
Walters and then she has to defend him
she has to defend him he he was I paid
for the best lawyer he said give me the
best lawyer because if she's still over
there at that same firm they're like we
just want you on big name people we
don't even care about yeah if she's
forced to represent forced to represent
very interesting and gets him off do you
know and that would put that strain on
her and Matt Murdoch's relationship so
quick he'd be like why are you doing
this and she'd be like it's my job like
they put me on it I'm just doing it
everyone deserves the right to
representation oh and that's when we're
like wow I hate her Matt Matt gets the
text that she's like I'm in town he's
like oh God my hips I can't take you
she's gonna stop vieing those hips we
saw what happened on that show the whole
house was shaking for go [__] no he
wasn't she she had sex as Jennifer
Walters not as sheh sometimes you know a
little bit of both oh my God dear Evan
over there rolling in his grave he's
already dead he buried himself in the
dirt and is rolling in his grave oh no
okay it's time for our heat check which
we haven't
done it's hot we haven't watched any of
these episodes but based on these
reviews I think you guys know how I'm
feeling about it yeah I'm still pumped
for it I'm hot for this show I'm very
excited for this show you know I was
like I said at the top I was really
concerned with the moving around the I
just putting it all at once you know
marvel has decided to do that but
they've also like Hey we're going to
launch a new thing called Spotlight it's
going to be more focused on singular
characters a little more down to earth
and like I'm I'm all for that so I'm
very excited for the show and yeah that
trailer really got me hyped for it and
yes these early reviews you could say
like oh these are shills oh they're just
simp blah blah blah but these are people
who watch everything that Mar puts out
and I think if they're willing to say
like hey there could be pacing issues
sure but like loving the tone of the
show loving where it's going I'm excited
for that will this be mcu's Andor maybe
I don't know what's Andor oh my God
apologies to Andor what's Andor
apologies apologies to Andor and that
you guys know that I'm I close she's
just being silly what's your heat check
on this no I already said I'm going to
love this show I'm I'm so excited for
this show I said I was excited for it
from the jump it's coming out my
birthday the trailer is amazing I will
probably be breaking it down um am I say
that yeah I think you will I think I'm
breaking this the echo we want you to
break it down I think you're traveling a
little bit at some point I don't know
it's my birthday okay well it's my
birthday what do you want to do break
down the show or have a birthday God
damn and that's it for the sneak peek
that's it for the sneak peek follow new
rockstars on Twitter follow Brandon at
what is it Gren and barck grin and baric
the puns follow me at Lulu Clemens the
puns
the pun and we'll see you guys next week
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
[Applause]
bye